[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he is a
former college quarterback former
college coach and
currently he is a college football
analyst for cbs sports the popular rick
new heisel
is joining us on the program rick your
reaction to
the news yesterday that 12 team playoff
is not a question of if but when
i'm in that choir singing
hallelujah hallelujah
we we need this uh and this is not
alabama or ohio state or clemson's fault
all they did was rise to the top of
college football and they had a strength
to hold on it
because every recruit wanted to be a
part of the college football playoff and
those were the three places
along with oklahoma i guess but they
never won one of the games
uh that you go if you wanted to be in it
and you know i think it was time that
we changed the format that allows a
little bit more
inclusion for other places especially
when
schedules are not alike uh you know
we've got
two conferences amongst the power five
still are only playing eight conference
games
so if you if you're not going to have at
least
some measure of equality from the
scheduling standpoint then
probably we need more spots and what
your what you just talked about in terms
of what it means financially you're
going from three games in the college
playoff format now to 11 games the four
play in
the quarterfinal games and then the
three that we've already got
maybe not changing who's ultimately
going to lift the trophy but certainly
give
more in the world of college football a
bite at the apple
any downside to this
uh i the only thing that i'm sitting
here going is this
a move towards better scheduled
games in the regular season and i'm not
sure that it does that
i don't think we've we've now put more
onus on
you know the alabamas of the world to
you know travel to los angeles to play
usc
i think that the one-off games are still
going to be where they'll go
that money game like they've got with
miami to start the season in atlanta
this year
i don't think we've done anything to
force the issue to get the home and home
games going
although there is a lot of those on the
books
in advance years so fingers crossed that
we'll get there because the college
football fan deserves that
well what about notre dame notre dame is
not going to be
in the top four they're not in a
conference here
and and yet jack schwarbuck was on this
i know
i know their athletic director so i
don't like
does this push notre dame to join the
acc now
and maybe jack swarbruck secretly
is hoping that's exactly what it will do
i mean you can't have looked at last
year's
year the one-off uh time in the acc
and say that that was unsuccessful for
notre dame
that was absolutely a great year for
notre dame and the fact that they were
in that league i think helped them
get to a place where uh
they were going to be part of the
college football playoffs they were
absolutely going to be there
and you know to play an acc schedule a
power five schedule
i think help them uh in some ways now i
know they've got a
you know a modus operandi where they
want to travel far and wide
you know touch each portion of the
country uh in the notre dame mission
but ultimately maybe this is exactly
what pushes them over the edge and gets
them
in the acc and i know that we have a lot
of blowouts there's going to be blowouts
because there's a big difference between
clemson alabama
and indiana or coastal carolina are you
okay with that
that you know the optics of this is
going to be
oh you know what why are we having these
games these are blowouts
and kind of embarrassing the playoffs
i well i'm first of all i'm thrilled
that we've
you know now got a surety
that the group of five is going to be
included at least one
group of five champions will be in the
hunt for this
and to start college football seasons as
we have in the past with really no
chance zero chance as dean wermer just
once said
0.0 uh when you when you
have a season that starts that way
something's wrong with the system
so now we've got at least one the
potential for two which should they uh
a conference champion come from the
power five that wasn't up to snuff but
ultimately that that's all good news i
don't worry so much
about those blowout games when great
teams you know are on the field that
happens it happens in the nfl
uh periodically and it will happen again
in this but
i remember back that georgia oklahoma
game in the rose bowl the overtime
thriller
i say we're going to have more chances
at that because
what will happen over the period of
years as this begins
is there will be more spreading of the
great players the great talent in the
united states
they won't all just go to the top three
places but knowing
that there are more chances to get to
the playoffs uh
maybe closer to home yeah i liken it to
gonzaga
because gonzaga used to be a novelty in
basketball
and you know they would be like oh
that's a cute story gonzaga
now gonzaga is getting some of the top
recruits in the country
and a lot of that is is they got an
opportunity if if the field was
32 as it used to be a long long time ago
you would have a lot of these programs
who would never get this opportunity to
grow their program
indiana being on a national stage with
their football program
i thought i would never see that in my
lifetime coastal carolina
you know they would make the playoffs
and i i like that it gives you an
opportunity to be seen by more people
because we wouldn't have seen the
indiana story this year or coastal
carolina
boise state wouldn't exist you know i
think having that opportunity where you
get to play against the big boys
and you know that opportunity for
players to see
or recruits to see you play i i think
it's a benefit for these smaller schools
that would not be
they would be dwarfed by alabama and
clemson and they may still be
but you just want to be in the
conversation that's it give me a seat at
the table
it can be a bad seat it can be an
obstructed view
just give me a seat at the table your
gonzaga
example is a perfect one butler uh is
another example right
the the gordon haywood shot off the
glass that you know everybody's still
gasping wondering how it didn't go in
those
moments now can be part of college
football you know i don't know that
we're going to see an appalachian state
knock off michigan
in the uh in the college football
playoff as we did
in the big house but it's possible and
now
when you have that possibility and you
can sit down in the living room
and talk about that possibility it's
much easier for that young man to say
you know what
i'm going to stay close to home here in
boone north carolina here in cincinnati
ohio or
boise idaho and i'm going to be a part
of this program because i want to take
to be the first ones to take them to the
college football playoff that's going to
be exciting
for those particular brands rick we're
sorry we let you down you did a great
song
for the emmy knight and uh we we're
losers
i mean it was it was a powerful powerful
song
that you gave us and maybe you could win
a grammy
before we win an emmy but uh just want
to thank you again
for uh putting that together i uh
i love the uh dan patrick show i know i
speak for millions when i say that
and your day's coming you two will be
the susan lucci
who will finally climb the final step
and on the the giant challenge thank you
rick
thank you we appreciate it have a great
weekend that's rick newheisel cbs sports
college football
analyst